c'est la onzième épidémie en rdc mais on
a encore beaucoup de choses à apprendre
de ce virus
[Musique]
notre pays est d'accord appelé à faire
face à une horde d'ennemis de la maladie
un virus ebola dans la province de
l'équateur
il ya des maladies comme ça et voilà à
partir du moment où il ya un seul cas on
parle d'épidémie
on parle d'épidémie parce qu'on sait que
la capacité de transmission de ce virus
est très importante à ce moment ça nous
permet de déclencher certains mécanismes
de prévention de surveillance qui sont
nécessaires pour lui limité contrôlé à
100 du virus
[Musique]
le
ce
[Musique]
le principal facteur c'est le soir nos
avoirs qui sont les animaux sauvages
on part on pense aux chauves souris on
pense aux prochaines phases et qui sont
présents dans la forêt et les
populations qu'on appelle en appeler
absolument les légumes mais qui vivent
dans ces dans ces forêts denses au
contact de terrain d'avoir donc le
contact la pluie dans plus important
c'est que les portables nation
[Musique]
on peut du non-coté avoir essayé de
l'imiter mais également il peut y avoir
l'aspect socio économiques qu'ils
faillent que les populations soient
poussés dans leurs retranchements du
fait des difficultés ou des particules
de guerre civile mais effectivement la
mobilité des patients 24 est certaine à
être plutôt contact de ce terroir
[Musique]
mais la grotte
ça passe
pour
[Musique]
dany
et le principal facteur est la forêt et
les animaux qui sont dans cette forêt
qui porte ce virus de toute façon tant
qu'il y aura des animaux temps
convaincante sans contact avec
l'écriture la possibilité d'avoir donc
ya très longtemps qu'on a compris qu'un
pays comme les garagistes et de brelles
apprendra à vivre avec
avec les mollahs on a le choléra qui
revient tous les ans les deux ans on a
les épidémies saisonnières de méningite
on a la grippe en europe maintenant il
faut vite donc ebola ferait partie de
ces maladies en tout cas eu un destin
qui arborait dans cette saison son et
des mouvements de population émouvant
les aliments également est la meilleure
chose à faire c'est fait la rdc était de
se préparer et d'être tout emploi répond
pas à l'équipe
toulouse est de renforcer les systèmes
de surveillance de renforcer les
systèmes de santé pour très rapidement
pouvoir capter le premier cas le
circonscrire
on puisse limiter la propagation du
virus
[Musique]
non